VO: This episode of Fun Science is brought to
you by Brilliant.
These are the lyrics to the theme song of
this very show.
CHARLIE: But despite the fact that I've been making
fun science videos for years,
and that I've written an entire Fun Science book, available in all good book stores,
I have never, ever, tried to explore
the actual science of fun!
But today that changes, in this episode of...
[FUN SCIENCE THEME SONG]
So, what is fun?
Well, surprisingly, science
finds fun hard to define.
Although we know that fun brings enjoyment,
not all enjoyment brings fun.
VO: For example, though I quite
enjoy listening to classical music,
I wouldn't really describe the experience as fun.
Although, someone else's experience might
be different.
CHARLIE: However, although fun is subjective,
we all experience it in the same way
when the chemical dopamine is released in our brains.
Now, dopamine evolved as a reward for behavior
that benefitted our survival.
So if you do something good for your species,
like reproducing, your brain releases dopamine
as if to say, great job, do more of that.
But science also shows us that it is possible
to have too much of a good thing.
VO: Take gambling as an example.
It might feel fun to win at first, but when
we repeatedly flood our brain with dopamine
in high dosages it can actually change the
structure of our brain, and thus our behavior.
This is what can form the makings of an addiction,
which definitely is not fun.
CHARLIE: But, provided that it's not excessive, fun
can definitely be good for you.
VO: It can help with depression, for example.
Studies show that doing something fun with
others, even if you don't initially feel like it
can still improve your mood dramatically.
CHARLIE: And fun can help us to be more creative.
In a study where 1,500 people were asked to
list potential uses for a jam jar and a paperclip,
those who ranked themselves as most playful
were also able to come up with more ideas,
like this one.
It's a paper clip container.
Pretty fun, right?
VO: Here's a 'fun' fact.
If you can convince your brain that you're
going on a run for fun rather than as exercise...
CHARLIE: I'm having a great time!
VO: Then you'll actually be less likely to eat
afterwords.
CHARLIE: My run was my reward!
And, while making time for fun is important,
apparently we have more fun when leisure activities
are loosely scheduled, say within a set window
of time, or better yet completely unplanned--
ANGELINA: Hey Charlie!
CHARLIE: What?
I'm kind of busy right now.
ANGELINA: Do you wanna have a
backpack fashion parade?
CHARLIE: DO I!?
VO: And although it is still fun to have fun all
by yourself,
we tend to have more fun when we do things with others, especially if they're our friends.
And what's a common side effect of having
fun together?
[LAUGHING]
VO: Laughter.
Scientists believe that laughter is related
to the panting sound that animals like chimps
and bonobos make when the engage in rough
and tumble play.
It's as if the laughter is there to signal...
CHARLIE: We're just playing and having fun.
ANGELINA: We're not gonna kill each other.
VO: And this signaling is helpful because play
can help us to learn things like social rules,
establishing rank, bonding, motor skills,
and managing stress.
CHARLIE: And maybe that's the best thing about fun,
and possibly the reason that
Fun Science exists in the first place,
because fun makes it easier
for us to learn...
So I hope you had fun, and I hope you learnt
something,
and if you're looking to learn more science with
the help of fun, why not try Brilliant?
VO: The people who built Brilliant understand
the important role that fun plays in learning.
They give you fun and challenging problems
to solve, getting you hooked on learning actively,
and helping you to master complex concepts.
Brilliant have loads of science courses to
explore, but why not start with their science
essentials course and refamiliarize yourself
with the basics?
To learn more go to brilliant.org/FunScience
and sign up for free, although the first 200
people who go to that link will also get 20%
off an annual premium subscription.
Anyway, that's all for today, thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you next time.
Bye bye!